Speaker 1: Let's go next to Ricky from
Charlotte. Ricky, you're on the air.
Speaker 2: Hey, David. Traveling, driving through
the country. So if you lose me with my bad
connection, if you just expand on a
topic that I just wanted to ask you,
how dangerous do you think it is that it seems
like the ideas of free speech and like freedom in
general are becoming branded as like a right wing
like Republican idea? And what can the left do to
sort of, you know, try to win some of that back?
Speaker 1: This is a major problem for the left.
So I've talked to before about how the right has
claimed for themselves a monopoly on patriotism.
They've claimed for themselves a monopoly on
free speech, they've claimed for themselves a
monopoly on being good at business. And none of
these things are true. I won't waste your time.
You already know that they're not true.
You're asking about what can be done and
the effect of it. I just think on the in
general, my view is hammering people with
facts doesn't really change minds. But on this
issue, we have to keep hammering with facts.
They are trying to ban the books, the book bands
that are a 20 year high. It's Republicans that are
doing it free speech. They talk about free speech
all the time, but they are the ones actually
limiting the speech of teachers, of protesters,
etc., etc.. I think there just needs to be
an on on message coordination on this that they
claim this stuff and it's not true. They say
they're better for the economy. Stocks do better
with Democratic presidents. Unemployment is lower,
job creation is higher, inflation is lower. We
just we need to all know the truth and we've got
to repeat it. Repeat it, repeat it.
Speaker 2: You know,
I've kind of noticed about that is it seems to me
like a lot of the political commentators on the
right are just more hack ish in, like the way that
they cover things. Yes. Like they have no problems
in like, you know, defending, like hypocrisy
with like politicians and leaders on their sides.
It it means they can keep their people in
power. But it seems to me like the left,
especially when you go to like now we call like
the dumb, dumb like like the Jimi two wars. Glenn
Greenwald like all those losers. Like they, like
they only care about, like the inconsistencies
on the left and like, they're so, like, overly
purist about it. And so I feel like that makes
it harder as well, you know what I'm saying?
Speaker 1: Absolutely. And you know, there's
a real question as to whether those people really
are on the left or are they just reactionaries at
this point. But very well said, Ricky.
Speaker 2: Yeah. No. Okay. I
appreciate it, David. Thank you.
Speaker 1: All right. Thank you. There is Ricky
from Charlotte. We will take a very quick
break. If you're holding on to talk to me
and you don't mind, keep holding because we're
going right back to the phones in a moment.